if you were to write a golden rule
of becoming wealthy what do you think it
would be live below your means and be
patient that's it that's 90
of finance that is 90 of finance not
even that's not even like the simplified
version
if you can actually do that you have a
you have a phd in finance
if the people of the internet want to
watch me and you mud wrestle for money
there is a there is a pay-per-view
audience out there
there's a there's i i have a price for
everything there's a price that says
there's a price on everyone's head
oh come on let's get started so this is
the
third time on the show this year so to
everyone on the internet who is
wondering
things are getting pretty serious
between me and morgan now
welcome back mate thanks for having me
i'm happy to be here i always enjoy
our conversations so i'm happy to come
back for a third and hopefully more
times after this we'll see if i don't
screw it up here for the third time and
hopefully there'll be a fourth
uh forthcoming later this year that's
the plan man that's the plan so
before we get started you got a new book
out psychology of money why should
anyone
listen to you on finances what your
credentials here's
here's the thing about money i don't
think that credentials necessarily move
the needle
that's not true in a lot of fields if i
wrote a book about medicine or aerospace
engineering or dentistry you should not
listen to anything that i have to say
finance though is very different because
finance what matters in finance is not
necessarily what you know
it's not about how smart you are or the
education that you have or the
sophistication the credentials that you
have
doing well with finances whether it's
investing or personal finances is
overwhelming
overall it has to do with how you behave
it has to do with just your relationship
with greed and fear
how you think about long-term thinking
and your who you trust how gullible you
are those kind of soft topics that is
not necessarily what you know it doesn't
matter if you went to harvard and you
worked at goldman sachs
if you lose your head during march of
2020
or in 2008 none of that stuff matters
anymore so what's important about
investing i'll give you my credentials i
have been
a full-time investing analyst and writer
for 13 years i've been
researching and focusing on kind of the
intersection of investing history
and behavioral finance the history of
how we think about money what we can
learn from those lessons and how we can
think about finances in a more
productive way
that's what i've done in this book is
kind of the culmination of the 20 most
important things that i learned
during that period i try to wrap it in
with a bunch of stories that have
nothing to do with investing
but they all have a really important
takeaway about how we can think about
risk with our money in a more coherent
way
i think that the way that you've written
this book you're my mate so i'm allowed
to i'm always going to gas you up anyway
i'm always going to say that it's good
but this particular style of writing
especially a non-fiction book
short sentences very snappy short
sentences
that sounds a lot like a dialogue i
think makes things easier to read
it's not a superbly a jump about like
read chapter one then read chapter 10
pick it up put it down as you want but
you could
and just i think coming out of that
blogosphere
coming out of the internet writing where
holding attention
is your primary currency right you just
don't want people to
click off the page um i really think
that that
is uh come to the forefront in a very
successful way man this
book is phenomenal and everyone that is
listening if you want it's the
rich dad poor dad of 2020 um with
with a better looking author i think
that's the
that's the thanks i appreciate that i'll
tell you what's important to me
i read a lot of books i know you do as
well but i've rarely finished books
like how often do i read to the last
page probably like one in 10 books
even books that i really enjoy and books
that i recommend to people a lot of them
i didn't read past chapter 5 or
something like that
and i think the reason is very few
topics require
250 pages of explanation to get your
point across it's just not the case
so even a lot of very good books after
chapter 2 chapter five whatever
you say look i i get the point it's a
great point i learned a lot from that
point
but i don't i don't need the rest of
this like you've made your point don't
like quit rambling on here
it was really important to me that uh i
wrote this book in a way that a it's
it's 20 short chapters well
at first the book itself is not that
long uh and each chapter is not very
long
uh either and every chapter can kind of
live on its own and that was important
to me because rather than making
one point that i rambled on about for
250 pages i wanted to make 20 points
where i made my point quickly and then
out of respect for the reader's time i
got out of your way
nothing more there's actually a book
that is one
page it's it's not even one page it's
like half a page
and when i turn that in the publisher
said what's is there something
what happened here are you missing
something here and i said no that's i
said no that's all i have to say
and they said well you know this is a
book do you want to go in a little bit
deeper do some more reach and i said no
that's all i have to say on the topic
out of respect for the reader i'm done
here you move on to the next chapter
and what is important to me i don't
think there's any way to track this but
the metric that i wanted to maximize for
when writing this
is how many people finish the book not
how many people bought it not how many
people open the first page
how many finished it now not everyone
will it's not for everyone i'm not you
know that's
that's a different topic but if it's
easy to read and you make your way
through because there's no
there's minimal rambling uh that's
that's what i'm aiming for
that is a lesson that so many authors
should learn and i think that we're kind
of out of that the particular example
that you're giving now
the blog post that could have been a
tweet that somehow ended up being a book
um like that shouldn't that's not the
way that it should be look keep it to
360 characters i'll read it on twitter
that's great
um fleshing out to that and you kind of
thirst trap everyone
because all of the lessons are in the
final few pages like the main main
like your synopsis of what the
actionable takeaways of what you can do
get
re-put together in the last few pages so
there's like a little carrot
to dangle um so it's called the
psychology
of money why should we be bothered at
all about the psychology of money
money's just numbers in and numbers out
isn't it
see that's what people get thrown off i
think i think that's the root of a lot
of financial problems for amateurs and
professionals
is that we want to think of finance like
it is physics
and in physics there are very clean
formulas there are there are precise
answers with precision that never change
over time so if you
roll a ball down a hill we can we know
exactly how fast it's going to roll and
that answer is the same today as it was
200 years ago very precise
investing is not like that at all it's a
human endeavor it's much closer to i
think
uh you know i i think the best analogy
is probably medicine
look in medicine there are facts there
are formulas there are precise things
that we know about how the body works
but people's relationship with medicine
is very personal and very nuanced and
very behavioral
a lot of what matters in medicine in the
modern world is uh how healthy are you
do you eat proper diet do you exercise
do you smoke how stressed are you
those are behavioral things that feed
into the process of modern medicine
but not in a in a really precise
scientific way it's this mushy nuanced
sociology driven thing um and i think
with medicine too if you take two people
with identical cancers
they might come to completely different
conclusions on what is on what is worth
it for them
one person might make chemotherapy throw
the sink at it another person might say
just give me some pain meds let me be
comfortable and i just want to let
nature take its course
and those answers might be right for
that for those two different people
there's no one right answer
finance is totally the same where i can
tell you what i do with my money
here's how much i save here's how i
invest it here's how i spend it
and that answer might work perfectly for
my wife and i and it might be
nuts for you or someone else everyone's
going to come to different conclusions
just like we do with medicine
so that's why i think the psychology of
money is so important the other thing is
like we
know how finance works we've made a lot
of progress
in terms of the technical side of
finance over the last hundred years
if you go back 100 years ago we didn't
understand
things like discounted cash flows uh and
you know
and and and and dividend discount models
that just that information wasn't in
the social sphere but we do now like
we've made like academic finance
has figured out how finance works and it
was left for us to exploit what is left
for us to get better at
is the psychological side of money got
you so what does money get us
obviously that what it what clearly gets
us is stuff
you know it's it's a thing that you can
use to buy stuff that's that's the
obvious answer
and look i like stuff as much as anyone
else i mean this is not a plea to live
like a monk
but there's a lot us that money does for
people and to me
it took me a while to figure this out
but once i kind of realized it it was so
transformational just for me personally
that what money does
is it gives you options over your future
and it lets you control your time
and i think the highest dividend that
money pays the best thing that i can do
with my money
is the ability to wake up every morning
and say i can do whatever i want today
it's a sense of independence and a sense
of freedom a sense of controlling my
calendar
that that lets me do stuff and it's not
to say that i don't like ferraris and
bentleys as much as anyone else if
i do but what i really want out of my
money that's going to make me happier
than any of those things
is enough savings enough wealth that
i've built up and saved over time
without spending
so that i have control over my future if
i want to if i want to quit my job and
do go do something else i can do that
i've got the savings for if i want to
move i can do that
take six months off i can do that if i
were to get sick
or there's an emergency it's it's fine
it's not going to force me into anything
i don't want to do
financially i've got savings to keep me
going it's that level of independence
that i want
charlie munger years ago um who's in
charlie monger is a multi-billionaire
and he once told someone he said i have
no desire to get rich
i just always wanted a glorious
independence and as soon as i read that
it was like that's that's me too
like do i want to be rich like sure do i
want you know the huge house on the lake
of course like anyone else of course but
what i really want is a glorious
independence that's what
that's what i want money to do for me
and i think a lot of people
want that as well without without
knowing it without having that
that point clarified to them it's like
they wouldn't explicitly say that but if
you
introduce that to them in independence
to do whatever you want
uh a lot of people would say yeah that's
actually what i want in life it's just
the freedom to do what i want
it's strange how people's desires get so
conflated right like the same as when
you ask people what would make you happy
and they think it's the house they think
it's the car they think it's the
new expensive bag or whatever it might
be but when you strip it back and you
listen to some
super eckhart tolle remind you that it's
to do with being present
and being in the moment or spending time
with people that you care about
cetera et cetera um but it does require
a morgan household an eckhart tolle or
whatever to cut through the kind of the
social norms
and what people expect and i think that
that's definitely one of the main
takeaways everyone that's listening
needs to go back because morgan's been
on twice already this year
go back and listen to episode one that's
like that's the prequel
then there was uh we did a special
covert edition
just as the market was going absolutely
berserk kind of late
march that's the that's a dvd extra uh
director's cut
uh and then this is the this is the
what's the third one the sequel sequel
this is the netflix special this is the
netflix special that is correct
um so yeah go back and listen to those
but what i can do
because you've been on so much is i can
quote you back to you
of all of my favorite stuff that you've
said so my favorite one
is um money allows you to do
what you want when you want for as long
as you want
with whoever you want without anyone
telling you otherwise
that is that's it that is what it does
for you so what does it not get you
what what doesn't it get you i mean i
mean look
money gets you a lot so what doesn't it
get you i think the better way to frame
that
is what are you likely to overestimate
getting from money
and a lot of it the the physical things
and i have to reiterate
like i i like nice things too but the
physical things you just get used to
over time
a lot of it is because if you were to
get a nice car or a nice house
you kind of move the goalpost of your
social economic status
so let's just use extreme examples let's
say you go out and buy a ferrari
you're probably going to start hanging
out with other people who have ferraris
and lamborghinis and aston martins and
all sudden your goal post has shifted
so if you're driving if you're driving
the honda civic then the ferrari level
looks amazing but once you get to the
ferrari level you're
you you just adjust your expectations to
that level and then and then the joy
that you get from it
the social status it's not that it's not
there it's less than you would think it
was
what's important about controlling your
time is this a lot of what makes people
happy is not adding
positive things it's removing negative
things and if you don't have control of
your time so let's flip this around
people who do not have control over the
time
people from whom they have to wake up at
a certain time and go to work at a
specific hour
and do things at work that they don't
want to do but their boss makes them do
it
your whole day is structured by someone
else's priorities that is the kind of
thing that is likely to
bring negativity to your life
permanently if you never have control
over your time
that is something that is statistically
correlated with people who are less
happy
than other people so it's not that
controlling your time adds happiness
necessarily it's that it removes
displeasure uh
and in in a way that if you were to do
it so people who have control over the
time it's not that they have
more good days is that they have fewer
days than people who are
uh don't have control over their time so
that's it's important way to keep that
into context too
and this is why people who are very
wealthy are not just
walking blobs of happiness like exuding
like pleasure
they're normal people just like everyone
else because having that money it
doesn't necessarily make you
it just removes a lot of the bad things
in life um
so that's i think that is what money
does not bring us it
we are we are i think programmed to
overestimate
the pleasure that we get from stuff and
even the pleasure that we get from
controlling our time
is a little bit more nuanced in the
sense that it's just removing bad rather
than adding good
being rich might not make you happy but
being poor will make you miserable
i think that's it my mother-in-law i
actually brought this up on your show so
i don't want to
i don't it's the camping analogy which i
love
get it out there tell us that's up my
mother-in-law brought up this thing
years ago where she said
camping is fun but being homeless is
miserable no the same thing you're
sleeping outside in a tent
but one is in your control one you are
doing on your own terms and one you're
not that's the only difference that it
makes but it makes
all the difference in the world so
that's i think that's it's the same
look for controlling my time most days i
will when i wake up
what i want to do even if i have control
over my time what i want to do is go to
work and do good work
and be productive like everyone else but
i'm doing it on my own terms on my own
time
with people who i like for a company
that i want to work for
and that makes all the difference in the
world it makes all the difference
so that level of independence is all
that i'm going for with money that's all
that i wanted
it's all that i'm really striving for in
terms of my financial goals
is just incrementally with every dollar
of sayings being less reliant on others
that i that i have that i
otherwise would be if i were in debt or
had no savings and was relying on the
kindness of others to make it through my
life financially
talk to us about how look and risk are
related i know that you bring it up in
the book and i think it's very
interesting the observation selection
effect that we have
of success or failure with finance and
the
total uh the total blind
uh blinkers that we have on either side
that don't allow us to see how luck and
risk
were involved so there's two points here
the first
is that luck and risk are actually like
the exact same thing
just just opposites but they're they're
they're they're cousins it's just
you know what one's a brother one and
sister they're they're
they're they're very similar both luck
and risk are this idea that
there are things that can happen in the
world that are outside of your control
that have a bigger influence on outcomes
than anything you did intentionally
that is what risk is that is what luck
is as well
things that can happen outside of your
control that have a big influence on
your outcomes
and what's interesting is that as
investors purely in finance we are
keenly aware of risk
investors talk about risk all day long
and they hire risk managers
and they adjust their returns for risk
everything about investing is i'm going
to manage risk manage risk manage risk
but no one talks about luck very few
people
uh no no investors hire luck managers
you're never going to see
you never see any investor who says look
i earned 50 percent last year but you
have to adjust that return for luck
no one says that
here's the thing if someone loses 50 in
the stock market they will say oh really
risky year
if someone makes 50 in the stock market
no one says oh really lucky here
no i didn't have anything to do with
that so luck and risk are the same thing
but we treat them so differently
a lot of this is look if i am ascribing
to someone else i look like a jerk if i
say look chris you've done really well
but you just got lucky
i that's that's a mean thing to say i
don't want to say that to you even if we
know
with certainty that luck exists in the
world i look mean if i'm describing it
to you
and if i'm ascribing luck to myself if i
say look i've had this level of success
but it was just lucky i didn't have
anything to do with it it's hard for me
to look myself in the mirror every
morning i don't want to admit that to
myself
so that's why luck just kind of goes
away whereas look if something really
unfortunate happened to me if my
industry collapsed
the company i worked for went out of
business then i would say oh it was a
risk
like i just you know i got caught up in
a risk in life but
luck is just a very different thing so
even if we know it exists it's just much
harder to
identify in real life we just go through
life kind of ignoring it
uh systematically everyone does i do
this too the other point about luck and
risk is that
particularly for extreme success who are
the people that we tend to study
people who tend to idolize or the ones
who've had extreme success or extreme
failure those are the people who pay
attention to
the line between huge success and huge
failure
is very thin and it's usually only known
in hindsight
people who are very successful tend to
have taken a lot of risk
and it's only and people who are very
unsuccessful took a lot of risk too this
ended up on the different sides of that
equation
so it's very difficult to really know
like if you have a hedge fund manager
that really swings for the fences
and let's say it works out for them
let's say because they swung for the
fences
there was a 10 chance that they would
have done really well and 90
chance that they would have failed well
if they do really well they ended up on
the
on the the fortunate side of the 10 odds
and then we say
that guy is a genius he's a billionaire
one of the great investors
because he ended up on the correct side
of the 10
odds if that person fails like they will
ninety percent of the time and they go
bankrupt we say this person has no idea
what they're doing even if they made the
exact same bet
if they just end up on different sides
of the luck versus risk equation
like it totally changes how we think
about them a really good example that i
use from this is a hedge fund manager
named monish prai who is one of my
favorite investors
he's not a household name but he's
really a great investor and years ago he
made an investment in a company called
delta financial
that went bankrupt he invested a lot of
money in it and a company went bankrupt
and he did an interview with a financial
magazine afterwards and they asked him
about them like what happened with delta
financial
and he said oh that was that was a that
was a smart investment it just didn't
work out
and they said something along the lines
of how can you say it was a good
investment if you it went bankrupt and
he said he said i would make the same
bet
again like the odds were in my favor to
do well in this investment
i just ended up on the unfortunate side
of risk like if if if you are making an
investment that has
a 90 chance of success uh
then you know there's 10 chance it's not
going to work and that's what he was
saying
thinking about the world
probabilistically is a smart way to do
it but it's so hard to do that because
we want to think in a deterministic way
we want to think the world is just black
or white were you right or were you
wrong
when it's not like that odds are really
nuanced and they're
much harder to wrap your head around so
that's that's the hard dynamic with luck
and risk that's easy to ignore
the problem as well is that in
retrospect you have no idea what the
other outcome could have been
it's always brilliant for people to post
talk their way through it i can't
remember
who the quote is from someone said you
never get fired for hiring ibm
right um and the same thing is true of
my friend rory sutherland from ogilvy
advertising
where he talks about uh you never get
fired for following the formula
when it comes to advertising if this
advert
is just the same brand
icon the little meerkat or the little
teddy bear or the big pirate or whatever
it is
uh in a new scenario and it doesn't land
and yeah but look we followed the
formula
like we did the same thing we've done
all the rest of the type hey man pat on
the back
yeah you know sometimes it just doesn't
work out dude like maybe we'll go again
it would be maybe the illustration was a
little bit off of the timing it's just a
little bit
but if you come in and you do something
really innovative
and it works you're a genius but if it
fails you're out the door
what do you want why didn't you follow
the why didn't you follow the formula
well the formula wasn't working anyway
i would much sooner fail safely than be
successful
riskily and yes and i understand why
people do that people are trying to
maintain their careers it's not i i
don't thought them for doing that but
it's a really important thing
to me one of the takeaways from the luck
risk dynamic is that we need to be
careful
in terms of who we admire and making
sure that
the people who we admire we're not
taking lessons away from those people
that are too specific
if i say i really admire this investor
this person
but i'm unable to ascribe how much of
their success was luck versus skill
then i need to make sure that i'm taking
away the broadest lessons for them
if i say this person invested in this
company in this way so if i do that too
i'll be as successful as them if you
take a hyper-specific lesson from them
that's where you're most likely to get
caught up versus a really broad lesson
that applies to a lot of number of
people
that is where we can be sure that there
is something there that we can hold on
to versus the hyper-specific
so a lot of people who idolize warren
buffett benjamin graham all these people
will take hyper-specific lessons from
them and try to apply it to their own
finances
what is the exact formula that warren
buffett used 40 years ago to pick stocks
and how can i use that today
that i think is a really dangerous way
to go about learning from anyone in any
field
i think the more broader it is the more
likely you are to find something that is
something that you can replicate
yourself
i think that is why i resonate with your
particular approach to financial advice
and there's a number of there's an
undercurrent at the moment in the um
online fitness world
uh we we had this period so between 2005
and kind of
probably about now where people were
able to put out
crazy diets where it's the 48-hour fast
or the
the the carnivore diet or the keto or
this this and this
and it's kind of all come back around to
it's just calories man
like it's just calories in and calories
out
like are you eating more than you expend
or are you expending
more than you eat and that's what it is
and it's this um
beautiful simplicity that i'm really
enjoying us all coming back to both with
podcasting as well like
this show's a good example i'm filming
on an absolute logitech
piece of [ __ ] c220 something same same
i'm doing the same
i'm filming on we're both doing it um
but
i think now the glitz and the glamour
and the fancy stuff people are kind of
through that and you might even see this
i've not even thought of this before
perhaps this is the same reason trump
got elected
that everyone was sick of the glitzy
very complicated lies they just want
kind of the thor
you know like that i'm not that is no
way an analogy between
physically donald trump and thor but the
the idiot the blunt instrument you know
that comes in like i can see through
the simple lines i want to know what i'm
going to expect
the same thing is true with finances the
same thing is true with stock picks and
investing advice the same thing is true
with
getting lean or losing weight you've
touched on uh
buffett there i didn't know you first
off i didn't know you had two thousand
books written about him which you
you drop in the book which is like
ridiculous what can we learn
from his wealth and from compounding
what's interesting about buffet like he
okay so he's the greatest investor of
all time he's one of the richest man in
the world
and if you dig into his wealth though i
think something's really interesting is
that
buffett started investing when he was 11
years old and today he's 90 years old
and he's a full-time he's still going at
it full-time
that fact the fact that he started so
young and conte
so late into his elderly years is so
fundamentally important to his success
his average annual returns over his life
have been about 22
per year which is phenomenal of course
but if you were to say okay let's
let's assume hypothetically that buffett
earned the same returns during his
lifetime
but instead of starting at age 11 let's
say he started at age 25
like a normal person and instead of
continuing through age 90 let's say he
retired at 65
to play golf with his kids just stopped
investing like a normal person retired
65
and earned the same average annual
returns during that period his net worth
today hypothetically
would not be 90 billion it would be 12
million
99.9 less than it actually is
99.9 of his success can be directly tied
to the fact that he started investing
when he was a kid
and he continues at age 90. that's what
his his
secret or his skill is that he's a great
investor
no doubt about 100 full stop but his
secret that has created this level of
wealth
is that he's been a good investor for 75
years and i think as you bring up in
those 2 000 books
that are writing about warren buffett
how did he do this what is his strategy
how does he think about business models
and moats and markets
none of those books would just point out
that we know
as a matter of simple math that the
reason he's been so successful is just
the amount of time he has been investing
for yes he's been a great investor so
you can dig into the business strategies
how he's dealt with
uh insurance float and debt how he
thinks about management teams that's all
really important
but what really moves the needle in
terms of the dollar amount of the wealth
he's been able to build is just the
amount of time he's been doing it for
and that is very often not mentioned
because it's too simple
it is too simple if you are a phd in
finance and you're trying to
ascertain how he did this and trying to
use your brain power use your knowledge
to pick apart how to invest like warren
buffett you don't want to just say oh
well he's been doing it for 75 years so
that's
that's it the other reason is that a lot
of people can't do this if you are 60
years old
and you're trying to invest like warren
buffett then telling you oh well you
know
you you need to invest for 75 years to
achieve these returns
well if you're if you're already 60
years old you don't want to hear that
so it's both too simple an explanation
and i think
it's a it's a painful explanation for
people want to hear it's a painful
reality
that the reason he has achieved this is
because he has done something that a lot
of us
just mathematically cannot do we don't
have that much time in front of us to do
that
which of course for that kind of success
of course he has done something that
most of us cannot do that's why he sucks
that's why he's worth 90 billion and you
and i are not like of course he's done
something that is extraordinary
um and i think so that's it's just too
simple in
this idea the other thing is that
berkshire hathaway his company
does not charge fees uh there's no fees
attached if you own
berkshire hathaway there's no fees in
charge buffett's total compensation is a
hundred thousand dollars per year
it's been that way forever just that
single fact alone if you are to compare
that to
a mutual fund or a private equity firm
uh just that fact alone that he doesn't
charge fees
accounts for a lot of his outperformance
over time you know he's outperformed the
market
uh by depends on what benchmark you use
if you're looking at private equity
funds by something like five percentage
points per year
well if you just fees alone accounts for
two to four percentage points of that
outperformance
but that too if you were to write a book
about how warren buffett has done it
no one wants to write in that book oh we
know that the majority of that
performance came from the fact that it
doesn't charge fees
it's too simple an explanation uh
charlie munger his long time business
partner was once
asked kind of how buffett and monger did
this
and buffett said monger said quote if
you're an observer you would see that
warren did most of it by sitting on his
ass
and reading and that's it and that's but
that too is just too
simple an explanation for people to take
seriously so there's always this thing
where
you know again if we are to think about
finance like it is physics
or like it is you know something really
complicated then the answers have to be
really complicated
but it's not so it's not intuitive to
think that the most important answers
are
really really simple and basic because
we want to use our brains to figure out
the secret sauce
even if it's just right there sitting in
front of you you want to say well okay
that's
that's cute and all but let's really try
to figure out what's going on but
neither is losing weight
losing weight is very very simple eat
less than you expend for a consistent
period of time
building a podcast or an online audience
post content that resonates or produce
content that resonates
and do it consistently for a very very
long period of time
100 i wrote an article a couple years
ago called
useful hacks and i wrote this because
years ago i said
a different employer my company hired a
social media
consultant to come in and gave a talk
about here's how to really maximize
twitter here's
the time of day you should publish and
how hashtags and how you can interact
with
all these like hacks to increase your
sold social media
uh presence he did not mention at one
point
during this consulting session that the
key to doing well on social media is to
write good content
that's it you want to do well in social
media write a good tweet
that people are interested in that's it
but you don't want to say that because
people want the simple strategy they
they want the hack they don't want to
put in
the the elbow grease they don't want to
grind it out
in a way just like buffy like what is
buffett's secret invest for 75 years
that's the secret
no one wants to hear that everyone wants
to everyone wants to say well okay okay
that's great but how can i do this
tomorrow yeah how can i do it today
it's a lovely idea but what how would
you do it in 35 and it's like that
first off especially doesn't doesn't um
allow for understanding how compounding
works
so it seems like with everything that
we've brought up actually with building
your social media
or building a good podcast or becoming
wealthy
long-term time horizons is a bit of a
uh the ability to suffer discomfort
long-term is a skill that everyone
should acquire
for a lot of industries health is
another one like you want to be healthy
over the long term you got to grunt and
sweat in the gym in the short run that's
the cost of it
you want to be healthy over the long run
you gotta you gotta push away the
twinkies and eat the broccoli
like there's a lot of things where the
short-term uh you know the short-term
cost of admission is the price of
long-term returns it's
true in investing as well um so i think
that's a lot of things i i said you know
you should
for money you should save like a
pessimist and invest like an optimist
be an optimist in the long run in terms
of hey if we invest in the economy
invest in capitalism invest in
businesses
you can do very well in the long run but
you have to save like a pessimist and
realize that the short term is going to
be a
constant never-ending chain of
recessions bear markets pandemics
uncertainty these things that we did not
see coming up
or at the personal level job losses
divorces medical
issues like ever you have to be able to
survive the short term
and able to achieve and benefit from the
long run i love it
is getting wealthy a different skill to
staying wealthy what are the
principles to keep in mind though
they're they're they are
it seems like they should be the same
thing like wealth is just a single topic
but
as i just mentioned saving like like a
pessimist investing like an optimist
that is getting rich versus staying rich
getting rich getting wealthy requires
optimism swinging for the fences doing
really well being optimistic about the
future
staying rich requires a pessimism about
the short run
where you're saying i don't know what's
going to happen over the next three
months i got to make sure i have a lot
of savings i got to reduce my debt
because i don't know if i'm going to be
able to keep my job
i gotta i gotta plan for you know
unexpected expenses that might come up
you have to those are two separate
skills that you have to nurture and
think about
separately and if you don't have one or
the other
if people are just optimistic about the
future and they're so optimistic that
they're really that
they are willing to push it in the short
run in terms of no
savings lots of debt because they're so
optimistic those are the people that end
up running themselves off a cliff
and on the other hand if you are
pessimistic about the long run
if you're just gonna save your money in
cash and cds
then you're never gonna get rich to
begin with so you have to foster both of
those and they are conflicting skills
which is why a lot of people don't
necessarily have them there's a lot of
turnover
on the forbes list of billionaires not
because they're all people who die it's
because they're people who became very
rich
but had no skill at staying rich and a
lot of it is the
skills that will get you to become rich
actually
counter the ability to stay rich a lot
of people who get rich are got rich
because they are so willing to swing for
the fences
they're so willing to take a huge risk
to bet everything
on this one big crazy idea that's the
skill you need to get rich
staying rich is the exact opposite
staying rich requires paranoia
diversification
uh pessimism that's what you need to
stay rich and if you don't have those at
the same time
uh you know it's then then
if you are fortunate enough to get rich
or whatever word you want to use just
well off
doing a little bit better than you are
it's probably going to be a temporary
endeavor
so i'm interested because i'm interested
in compounding i want to
i want to make sure that i can maintain
the level of financial
uh you know you know wealth that i have
right now
for the longest period of time as i'm
not interested in doing something for
the next year even 10 years
i want to remain invested remain
compounded for the next 50 years
and the only way that i can do that is
if i am paranoid about the short term
in a sense that is going to make me have
a high savings rate lots of cash no debt
in a way that is almost completely
counter to my long-term optimism
cultivate your paranoia morgan household
2020 that's the
that's the synopsis that we've got
2020 is actually the perfect example of
the continuous
chain of breaking disappointments that
happens to all of us
that we need to manage for no one
thought that 2020 was going to end up
this way
no one saw this coming but if you look
historically i think the world breaks
about once per decade
not not on that exact timeline but on
average once a decade the world falls
apart
covet 19 2008 financial crisis september
11th
7 7 for for the uk every 10 years
something bad happens
you go back great depression world war
ii jfk assassinated on and on and on
so if you just use that as your
historical baseline i don't know
when it's going to break or what is
going to be the cause it's not a
prediction of
specific events but the world is prone
to breaking
and if you view that then it just pushes
you towards more
safety security room for error in your
finances for the short term
but even though the world breaks every
decade there's been tremendous progress
over the long term
so i want to so to acknowledge the
constant breakages
i'm pessimistic about the short term uh
but to
exploit the long-term optimism i'm
optimistic about the long run
so those are since those are not they
seem like opposite it's hard to put
those two together but they're both
necessary to do well over time i love
that there's a
really good example from mutual friend
shane parrish
mr farnham street where he talks about
signal versus noise and the example the
first ever example that he used
uh or the first ever example that i
heard to explain signal versus noise is
a mental model is this one
and he says imagine that you're an
investor and you put your money in the
stock market and you were tracking where
your investment had gone
and you looked once a year at what your
investment had done
he says imagine that you get 50
useful information and 50
totally useless noise and he says now
let's increase that frequency
let's check every one month to 12 times
a year
well now you're getting towards like 90
percent
noise and only 10 signal because there's
a load of little wiggles around
anyone that's ever looked at the graph
on a stock market looks like a spider
going for a walk
he says and now imagine that you're
going to check every day
and that is 99.999 percent
noise and only one percent signal and
that
um ability to first off the
luxury that you don't have to feel like
you need to check it i don't know how
often you check your vanguard fund i'm
gonna guess it's just
when you want not when you feel
compelled to it's not every morning when
you wake up that you
wake up and crap your pants because like
where's the vanguard phone going
i i check it when the market's gone up
and i don't check it when it's gone down
it's a really useful skill to making me
believe that i'm only going up over time
i'm only half kidding about that i'm not
but here's the thing i don't make any
actions when i check i like checking it
because it's fun to watch but i don't
change anything
so i think it's fun i think it's fine to
check your portfolio often
as long as you're just checking it it's
dangerous if you check it and every time
you check it you are tempted to say oh
maybe i should sell this maybe i should
buy that turn the levers do this
that's when i think it gets dangerous um
and back to your shane partnership your
shane example you know checking your
portfolio every day
let's talk about the robinhood traders
it might be checking it 47 times a
minute
like we're at a different world here and
that is of course back to luck and skill
the shorter the time period that you're
looking at the more likely that the
results are the result of uh
of of luck or or risk and it's not until
we've
the longer you look the more you can say
okay this was this is skill
the longer period of time through a
variety of different environments
recession boom bust if you can do well
through all those
periods that's something you can say
okay there's a skill there
but the shorter the more you shrink the
time rising it's just going closer
closer to luck
risk noise that you're looking at tell
me that you've seen
the wall street bets subreddit
i've heard i've heard of it i've i think
i checked it
i'm not a frequent observer dude this is
like this is like softcore porn to you
this is just the most
entertaining so everyone that's
listening and you once were done morgan
goo go onto youtube and search wall
street best
dankest trades oh my god they put
together the highlights of this
subreddit where people just make
outrageous they bet their entire live
savings
on the fact that apple's going to go up
by 10 by the end of the week
or down by this and dude it is it makes
your bum hole
like sort of do this like clenching
thing a little bit
and um you know those um those videos of
free climbers and they'll be on doing a
handstand on the top of a skyscraper
that's still a building site
that sweaty palm sensation is precisely
the same thing that you get when you
watch these videos
dude it is it's so compelling so i i
urge everyone to go and do it and if the
guys from
wall street bets are listening you're
heroes you're crazy but you're also
you're also heroes as well if you were
to write a
golden rule of becoming wealthy what do
you think it would be
uh live below your means and be patient
that's it that's ninety percent of the
finance that is ninety percent of
finance
that's not even that's not even like the
simplified version if you can actually
do that you have a you have a phd in
finance
that's really fast because here's the
thing i mean let me let me
walk through this living below your
means it does not matter how much money
you earn you can earn 10 million dollars
a year if you spend 11 million it
doesn't that doesn't matter you're not
building any wealth
obvious obvious statement but we need to
say that that
how wealthy you grow is not about how
much money you make it's about how much
money you save
so living below your means at any income
level whether you make 10 000
a year 10 million dollars a year is the
key that you need for finance to build
wealth over time
and being patient again is just putting
the odds of success in your favor the
shorter the period of time the more
you're relying on luck to fuel your
success
whereas the longer period of time the
more you're putting your odds in your
favor so if you can
live below your means and be patient in
your investment that's it
you're done game over anyone who's got
finances phd that's listening i'm very
sorry
had josh going on josh kochman on
recently who
said anyone who's gone and paid 20 grand
for an mba doesn't need to just read my
book
so there we go we've saved we've saved
people across the entire world
hundreds of thousands of dollars uh what
were some examples that you found of
rich people doing crazy things
oh i mean they're endless i mean i mean
the the thing that that you that you
brought up
with wall street bets you know a lot of
those people have money and they just
can't
i my wife and i often remark whenever we
see someone doing something we say
something like that we say people hate
money people that cannot stand money
they think they want it but as soon as
they get it they're like how can i get
rid of this
as quickly as i can doing the most
ridiculous thing that i can
they hate money uh so i think i think
there's
there's a lot of that i opened the book
with the story about when i was in
college i worked at a very nice
fancy hotel in los angeles i was a valet
and there was a guy there who was
very smart very successful he was a
technology entrepreneur
he had built and sold several companies
he was filthy filthy rich
but his relationship with money was
unlike anything i had ever seen he was
the quintessential of what i just said
uh could not get rid of money fast
enough
and one day he was i mean he was he was
he was a drunk too he was always uh
he was a very colorful guy and he came
to us when we were always running these
crazy errands for him as valets
um and he came to one of my colleagues
one day and he said
he carried around this thick stack of
100 bills and he peels off
like half an inch 100 bills and he says
go to the jewelry store down the street
and get me some gold coins
my friend the valley goes out and does
this comes back with the gold coins
and this technology entrepreneur and his
friends stand at the edge of the pacific
ocean
on at this hotel and they take these
gold coins and they start skipping them
like rocks see whose can go the farthest
and they're
cackling they're just laughing at who's
gonna go the first as far as i know that
as far as i know the coins are still
there maybe we should
we should go get them but uh anyways
at the time i i was young and i didn't
really understand but i
remember watching this guy being like
how long can this last
how like how sustainable is that
relationship with money
and i learned years later that he went
bankrupt uh surprise surprise
as everyone should should assume so this
gets back to
the thing that was so astounding about
it is that he was a genius he was a
technology entrepreneur that created
these incredible products
uh but his relationship with money just
completely blew it all
uh so let's get back to you can be the
smartest person in the world and have
all the analytical skills but if your
relationship with money is not
well honed none of it matters it all
goes away so
you see a lot of people uh do similar
things now
i hypothesized on one of our episodes at
the beginning of this year
i proposed that people have a
materialism set point
kind of like you have this hedonic
adaptation you have like a materialism
set point which is um inbuilt somehow
into you i didn't know if it was
psychological or if it was genetic and
it would have been influenced heavily by
were you in a family that
gifted very heavily around christmas
time and birthdays was it very much
keeping up with the joneses sort of
environment and my prescription was
if that is the way that you are that you
show love in the world that you feel
um acclaim and success you better hope
that you get a good job
like you'd better hope right that you
are the director of some huge company or
your investments go well or you
get into angel investing or whatever it
might be and i had a psychologist
on the show very recently called fiona
murden who wrote a book called mirror
thinking about the mirror neuron
and i brought this up with her because
it sounded like what she was talking
about and she says that is precisely
what people have
they have a materialism set point the
same way as we have a hedonic set point
the same way as we have a happiness set
point there is a an
amount of spending that we are used to
and
that um is kind of a little bit of an
immutable truth
what we're talking about what we're
trying to do here is
uncouple someone's ability to create
wealth from where they started look
if you follow this particular process
you can achieve
some respectable returns yep
this the materialism set point and the
this hedonic set point that you have as
well that is a little bit less
meritocratic
that is something that's kind of either
a blessing or a curse depending on which
side of the coin you fall on and
where your life ends up um and for that
as well i think that's
really important for people to realize
they should do some internal work
think look do i need to actually work
this hard
for me i think the same as yourself i'm
happy just i like a nice coffee
like would i pay if i was a millionaire
would i get a slightly nicer coffee
well yeah maybe but you know just i
don't spend tons of money i like a nice
car but i don't
i don't need an insect would it be fun
to have a helicopter yeah of course it'd
be fun to have a helicopter
but i don't need a helicopter but there
are people out there who have to have
the levuton bag
they have to have the the red bottom
sheet they go you know they have to have
everything
and for those people they need to um
look at themselves very very carefully
and think right
how can i curb the areas of my
psychology which aren't
aligned with long-term wealth accrual
and how can i service those in the most
uh i suppose the most prudent way
possible yeah
that brings up two points that i think
are really important one is that
um i think the most important financial
skill is getting the goal post to stop
moving
if you are fortunate enough to be
someone whose income and wealth is
growing over time
if your expectations grow in lock step
or if your expectations grow higher than
your income
none of it matters it's not going to
feel that great to you and i think a lot
of the reason why people are
somewhat disappointed with the wealth
that they might be lucky enough to
create when they get there they say oh
this doesn't feel like i thought it
would
it's because if you are uh if you are
you know
at a low level of wealth and you dream
about what it would be like to have a
million dollars
you are using your current expectations
and then
and then transplanting yourself into
someone who has a million dollars so
there's a big gap between
your current expectations and a million
dollars but once you get to a million
dollars your expectations go up to a
million dollars too and then it doesn't
feel that great anymore you start
looking at people who have 10 million 20
and 50 million
and that never ends uh so getting the
goal post to stop moving
is the single most important skill
because being happy with your money is
just the gap between what you have and
what you expect
so if those two things move at the same
level you're never going to feel that
great with your money
and keeping your expectations low and
having a sense of enough
it's not to say that you don't want more
but you need to have a a well-honed
ability to say okay this is enough this
is all that i need
if i get more than that like the great
that's a cherry on top but
my expectations are not going to exceed
this level that level might be different
for everyone
and even different at different points
of your life but if you don't know where
that level is and if you're not trying
to keep your expectations below it going
out of your way to keep your
expectations below it
you're going to have a hard time with
money no matter how successful you might
be lucky enough
to be in your life sort of earn rich
think poor i suppose is one of the
other little maxims that we can pull out
of so far we need
financial role models though right we
need someone to aim for an example to
follow
and that someone has to be properly
financially smart
and not just like with the flashy
displays of wealth like the
fellow with the the gold coins um but
also you had this story about janet
who's say four million
that really to me that's not a poor
that's a poor role model as well because
it's not a life i would find very
exciting
it doesn't you know it doesn't really
fire me up oh yeah i'm gonna not
i'm gonna live in a tiny flat for all my
life and then give away three million
dollars to
charity after i'm dead so who should we
try and emulate is there a perfectly
balanced financial role model that you
know of that everyone can just go and
follow on instagram or something
no because the point that i want to make
is that it's very different for everyone
there are people uh not you and not
necessarily me although maybe i'm closer
to it who would not
who would not aspire to be someone like
ronald reed the janitor who gave away
four million dollars
there are people who would be like
that's that's exactly what i want to do
i don't know if you saw the news just
yesterday the guy who started
duty-free stores in airports his name is
chuck feeney
his net worth at one point was eight
billion dollars from starting duty free
stores
he gave away every he kept 2 million for
hit for he and his wife
2 million with an m and gave away the
other 7.9999 billion
and just as of yesterday as the the news
story came out yesterday
he has officially given it all away his
net worth is now two million dollars he
lives in a small
apartment uh he flies coach he drives
like a volvo
uh so for him that is that is the dream
he never had
any material aspirations above two
million dollars
and other than that it was like just get
all i want to give everything else away
to charity
other people are not like that so it's
different for everyone and that's why
there's no one financial role model
that we can all look to because what is
what i want might be very different from
what you want very different from what
chuck feeney wants
and other people so this gets back to
the idea that personal finance is more
personal than it is finance
everyone is different and what i want to
do might make no sense to you
and you might criticize it and say how
can you how could how does this make
sense the thing that i'm doing with my
money how does it make sense how does it
make you happy well for me it does and
then and for my wife it does so
and like you you can do your own thing
and that's fine too
i think health is really similar i run i
i don't lift weights but i run
but i'd almost i i've increased it a
little bit uh recently but i never run
more than
three to five miles could i run could i
train for a marathon and do that
probably i think i think i'm capable of
doing it but i don't necessarily aspire
to do it because my goal for running is
not to become the greatest athlete to
push the limits as hard as i can
to do well in a marathon my goal with
running is to keep my health adequate
enough
that i don't gain a lot of weight over
time that like that's that's full stop
that's my goal
same like if i do lift weights once in a
while it's not like how can i get
how can i get huge how can i get ripped
it's like how can i make sure that
that that my bones are staying strong
enough over time that i'm not just a
total couch potato and that's it i don't
aspire for anything more than that
so that i think people have the same
thing with money uh what my goal is
might be totally different from yours
just as my health goal is probably
different from yours as well
we're out of the safe zone now we're no
longer in your book and i'm going to ask
you some questions i've had planned
since
our earlier episodes this year what is
your response
to the people that say that morgan
housel can't pick stocks
name me one big stock pick that morgan's
got right over the last 10 years
index funds aren't financial advice
morgan doesn't know what he's on about
well uh the index funds that i own have
big positions in
amazon google netflix apple uh
so the odds are that i have owned more
great stocks than you mr stock picker
have
so take it look over a long period of
time over a long period of time i i'm
happy to compare my returns to anyone
else's because
look we know statistically that uh
people who try to beat the market
90 of them will fail which is how it
should be that's of course that's how it
is like
what kind of world do people expect
where everyone who tries to make a
fortune in the stock market can that's
crazy
like i i used this example before of if
you look at college
uh sports players what percentage of
them make it to the pros
it's like two to five percent depending
on what you're looking at
uh no one says that's wrong no one says
that that's bad
no no no one says college sports is a
fraud people say look
it should be hard to make it to the pros
that's exactly what you would expect the
pros are the pros because it's the best
of the best
and beating the stock market is the same
which is why ninety percent of people
who try it over the time fail
which means that myself as an index fund
investor i almost almost certainly
by definition will be will end up the
course of my life in the top 10 percent
of money managers
which is just to say like people can
criticize it all they want but over a
period of time
i'm i'm happy to compare our returns
especially because
the index investor probably has the
highest odds of leaving it alone
and actually letting it compound for 50
years versus the the fund manager who
might you know fund managers retire or
they go on to do something else or they
you know they reach a rough patch and
their clients take out all their money
i think i have the highest odds of just
keeping this and letting it compound for
50 years
then i would if someone could uh then in
an active strategy
that is not to say and this is where i
differ from a lot of index fund
investors
do i believe that some people can
outperform the market over time yes
do i believe that there are people who
can pick winning stocks better than ours
yes
100 percent a lot of index funded
investors will tell you no it's just
impossible
i won't tell you no i just think it's
hard i think just like
are there are there college basketball
players who will go on to be better than
lebron james
yes it's hard not very many of them of
course it's hard but yes
of course it's possible and it exists so
that's that's
that's where i land on the on the
investing strategy i also make this
important point
it's probably the most the most
important point that the way i invest
works for me
it might not work for you and i don't
mean that in a dismissive
passive aggressive way if if if
something works for you
then then do it this works for me this
is how i uh
keep my head on straight and be happy
and go to bed at night saying like i'm
really happy with my finances
if you have a different strategy that
works for you 100 that's the one that
you should pick
another thing to consider is that your
particular setup financially permits you
to not
have to do work once it's in it's in
which i guess is also a good uh strategy
for sex
that you know it's just there it's in we
leave it there we don't we don't take it
out not until
the time is right um there is some
conclusion but yeah
um whereas what's the cost we talked
earlier on about like
unseen costs of money if your investing
strategy if you're scalping
and you've got to wake up and have a
line of cocaine and five coffees before
you begin your workday and sit down at
your seven
seven screen super computer that you've
got set up in your in your office or
whatever
that is a very different sort of life
now for some people there is there are
some people out there
who are built for that they love the
adrenaline they love the anxiety they
love the
the rush of just picking it perfectly
deploying the trades
all the take profits trigger at the
right blah blah all this stuff
and then there's other people and
there's everyone in between um and yes
for me
my particular lifestyle is anything for
an easy life
i want as much passive investment as
property here's something i haven't even
said i know a lot of people ask i own a
few houses in the uk that are buy to
lets i rent them out
to students and to young professionals
i'm going to pivot to become managed
from probably later this year and that
is
simply for this situation i've done
another round of move-ins
uh june august and september
and the tenants are lovely but it's just
too much of a headache i can't be asked
to do an inventory again
i can't be asked to tell them how to
work the washing machine
or where the stopcock is or why the this
like the banister's a bit wobbly or any
of that i don't want to deal with it
anymore and i'm happy to give away
eight percent a year of that to
make it someone else's headache right
but that's right the only reason that i
know externally what i want is because
internally i've done the work i've
aligned
my financial setup with my psychological
makeup
and that's what everyone needs to do and
look someone could say chris
why don't you want to earn an extra
eight percent do you just not like the
wealth do you not like the money you
don't want to earn it you you don't
think you can earn extra money and your
response is like no of course i could
it's just not worth it to me given the
risks
and the the amount of effort that i
wanted today it's the it's the headache
you know do i know investors who can
outperform the market yes
why don't i invest with them a lot of it
again is because uh
uh the odds that i would not be able to
maintain that strategy over time are
higher than they are for me right now
but the other thing is like look i i
could earn higher returns but i put that
in the same bucket as saying i could
also
double my salary if i got another job
and worked you know
until 4 a.m every day i'm just not i'm
not interested in that
there's a cost to all of this there's
there's a cost to trying to beat the
market
and i think for me that cost is not
necessarily worth it given the re
the goals that i have and keeping the
goal post pretty low that i have where
it's like
if i can and stay invested in index
funds for 50 years
i will achieve every goal that i have
and then some so why am i going to take
more risk
risks that might put me below my goals
to try to get there
there's this great quote from warren
buffett that i use in the book where he
says if you risk
something that is important to you in
order to gain something that is
unimportant to you
that is foolish there's no reason that
you should do that risk something that
is important to you to gain something
that is not important to you
why would you want to do that so why am
i going to risk the money that i have
that i need
in order to gain money that i don't need
because it's above my goals why would i
do that
the reason that that happens again and
this is why the psychology of money
does make sense as a title is because
people think that that's what they want
i don't think people do it some people
do it perhaps unthinkingly but most
people are fairly obsessive about money
when especially when it comes to
investment
spending they can be frivolous
investment they tend to be obsessive
especially if they're type a
and for this they're like no no that's
why that's what i want that's what i
need it's like
if you spent before before anyone
gets a robin hood uh account they should
have to do six months of mindfulness
meditation
because they're investing strategy would
be so much different
journal for your meditation 15 minutes a
day for six months and your investing
strategy will change far more than if
you read
like the two thousand books on warren
buffett
i need to bring this you know what that
would do to robin hood's business model
they they
they they might lose some that might
increase their customer acquisition
costs a little bit but yeah
i agree it would be totally different i
mean a lot of things with robin hood is
that
um it's primarily it's primarily young
men doing this
and look you know how the story is going
to end they're they're they're all going
to lose money you don't know when
you don't know exactly how long it's
going to last but you know they're all
going to lose money 100
100 odds a lot of that is a good lesson
to learn
to learn that the hard way is actually a
great way to learn it
and if they can learn that lesson when
they're young versus when they're 47 and
trying to put their kids through college
then okay great like maybe that's a good
thing there's also this thing with robin
hood where
we can't just pretend that this is a
game like this is real people's savings
that can really screw up your life
there's a story in the united states
maybe some of you have heard of it
of a guy a robin hood trader i think he
was 20 years old
he logged onto his account maybe this
was two months ago and there was a
glitch
in the ui it wasn't reporting things
accurately and he had he put ten
thousand dollars into a robin hood
account
and he logged into his account and his
account balance was negative seven
hundred thousand it was just a glitch in
the ui it wasn't that actually wasn't a
real number but he killed himself the
next day
because he thought he owed this much
money 20 years old uh
which is just to say like again this is
not a game we can't just say buyer
beware maybe you lose your whole
life savings like best of luck we can't
just we can just gamify this
and say you know buyer beware i think
there is a sense where it's like no we
need to be able to
we need to be teaching people the right
way to do this but there's also a sense
of
i'm glad in some way that they're
learning these hard lessons
through real experience versus just
reading about it someone else going
through it they're learning it they're
going to burn their own fingers doing
this maybe there's some
something positive about this even if we
should really have this idea that it's
not a game these are real people's lives
and real pieces of people's emotions
that are being toyed with i'm telling
you shortcut to success
dankest trades of wall street bets on
youtube it'll teach you all that you
need to know that's that's a dvd extra
first you read psychology money
then you watch dankest trades of wall
street bets the most hilarious thing to
do with the wall street bets sub 4.
remember that this subreddit is everyone
is trading on robin hood
right robin hood have
their own as many brands do they have
their own reddit account
and they joined and they tried to be a
part of the conversation instantly
banned by the moderators never to be let
back
they were like we don't want you here
[ __ ] you we're going to use your system
did you hear about the guy who found the
infinite money glitch by moving it
between robin hood yes robin hood cash
and robin hood gold so that was part of
wall street bets as well
and this guy turned like 1 000 into 50
000
then managed to get himself into like
half a million
when it was on bloomberg like uh
business and all this sort of stuff he
made national press
dude it is phenomenal speaking of
phenomenal trades
can we talk about bill ackman this year
yeah
i mean holy sh [ __ ] yeah he's swung for
the fences a lot
uh i i i don't i don't know a lot of the
details about it i i know
if i recall right so i might be getting
this wrong but he was
he went on cnbc in like march and was
talking down the economy we're all going
to the great depression and then it was
revealed that he was short the market is
that is that
the gist of what it was he put a very
specific type of insurance
onto his trades i think i don't
necessarily think that he shorted the
market
i think he put a very specific very
expensive type of insurance on his
trades
that protected him against this this
exact thing and he
the returns that he made was in the
billions so they're calling it the new
big short
which obviously the movie made about but
the difference is
that ackman's short took six weeks
it took six weeks to happen not not five
years like the actual big short with the
housing
exactly exactly so that i mean
bill eggman for all the he is he tried
to take down herbalife he's been in some
sort of he's one of these guys who's
super
um prevalent very very prominent as well
like a high visibility when it comes to
especially short like short investing
but [ __ ] hell man like what do you
say to that what do you say to a guy who
makes his investors like
billions in weeks you only need to do
that
once or twice in your career and then
the rest of the time you can do whatever
you can go buy whatever mansion you want
go to every club that you want get in
all the trouble that you want if you
have one of the if you have two of those
in
your career and that's that's your free
pass but i think that like let me make a
serious comment about this
a lot of no not a lot every one of the
best investors over time
um their career success is tied to a
handful of trades
and what they do in the other years
don't necessarily matter they don't move
the needle
it's like once every 10 years or once
every 20 years they completely knock it
out of the park and then the other 19
years they're just kind of
meddling along that's always how it
works so i think the bill ackman story
is instructive because that's how it
works forever
berkshire hathaway warren buffett uh but
monger said if you take berkshire's top
five investments out
they made dozens of investments take out
five they're berkshire's long-term
trackers average
it's just five big investments geico
general reed that have really moved the
needle
and you know apple is the other one
berkshire's made now something like a
hundred billion dollars in profit
if berkshire makes a hundred billion
dollars in profit all the other little
investments that people
you know look at or the the other failed
investment statement none of that
matters make 100 billion from apple what
wipes everything else away
so that like tail-driven success that we
see with ackman that's that's ubiquitous
across
all very successful investors what's
happened with tesla
and apple this year is the market
sentiment and the price just become
completely unhinged from the real world
what's going on
yes completely but then but the really
important question is how long can that
last
like just because you found something
that is unsustainable does not mean you
know when it's going to become more
sustainable
like things can so if is it crazy today
yes i
i i joked with a friend i i i wasn't
joking i said
i feel like there are as many teslas as
hondas on the road these days
i see teslas i live in seattle they're
everywhere and he said okay you're wrong
honda sold 10 times as many cars as
tesla but let's assume you're right
let's assume tesla sales are equal to
honda sales
honda is worth one tenth of what tesla
is one-tenth
they've their sales are ten times higher
and the company's worth ten times less
so yes you look at something like that
and it's like of course it's ridiculous
but that does not mean you know when
it's going to turn or it does not mean
that tesla cannot
increase another 10-fold from here like
just because something is crazy does not
mean you know the boundaries of insanity
is is what it comes down to so that's i
i
i don't i don't i don't have any bets or
on where it's gonna go
betting against elon musk has never has
never worked out for anyone
there are a lot of people who are
totally convinced that tesla was a short
at a hundred dollars a share and then it
went to
3000 or whatever it was so uh
it's fascinating to watch but i don't i
don't place any wagers on where it might
go from here
never underestimate people's ability to
like fuel crazy things for longer than
you might think
and never underestimate elon musk that's
definitely something to say any man
that can drill holes under the ground
and then fly cars along it
you just don't you don't want to mess
with him so we'll finish when he was
like 29 he made a life bet to colonize
mars you're going to bet against someone
like that
what were you doing at 29 you weren't
colonizing mars
are you colonizing mars at all no yeah
exactly so of course he doesn't of
course this is a guy who does not think
the normal rules of corporate boundaries
and innovation boundaries apply to him
didn't he get together didn't he get
taken off the board of tesla
after he got accused of of stock
manipulation through tweeting
so he got taken off he got taken off the
board or something and then just kept
tweeting
and that's again if you have the
personality that you think
at age 29 you think i'm going to
colonize mars and actually built a
rocket ship
that is legitimately making progress to
do that
of course you don't think that the that
the the boundaries of social decorum
around tweeting apply to you
if you think you can colonize mars of
course you think you can tweet whatever
the hell you want without repercussion
of course you don't if you think that
you can take on
gm and toyota and build a car company
that's gonna be worse than them of
course you don't
think that you need your lawyer's
permission to send out a tweet like that
person out the things that people love
about elon musk
is the fact that he does not think the
rules apply to him that's what we love
about him so we should not be surprised
when he he does things that look bad
because he didn't think the rules
applied to him like you have to take the
negatives with the positives what people
love about elon musk
is the fact that he does does not care
about what you think about him or what
lawyers or regulators think about him
he's going to do whatever he thinks is
right
and there are positive attributes to
that and negative attributes to that so
if you're a tesla investor
saying i don't like him tweeting he's
he's gonna keep tweeting he's getting
this is the same for donald trump it's
just integral to who we are and the
reason people like trump
is because he tweets like he does so you
should not be mad at him when he tweets
like he does that's part of the package
who's gonna win the election in november
uh in january i did
i did a conference and someone asked the
same question and i said i'm going to
give you the worst
answer that eddie punder can give which
is 50 50.
that's the worst answer no one wants to
hear that answer but i think it's
i think it's the truth i don't i don't
think it's any more than that
uh i i i wish i had more to give you
than that but
anyone who thinks biden is a is a slam
dunk and he's way ahead in the polls
i think is is obviously overlooking what
happened in 2016.
uh because of the electoral college
system there the republicans have a
legitimate head start advantage in this
so even if biden is ahead in the polls
hillary clinton had almost the same odds
to win that joe biden does today
and anyone who thinks trump is a slam
dunk is probably overestimating uh
the idea that what happened in 2016 was
low odds it happened it occurred and it
could happen again
but if you say oh well trump won in
2016. so he's going to win 2020
that's not how it worked i'm going to
give you again the worst answer
that no one wants to hear which is 50
50. douglas murray
uh contributor associate director or
whatever he gives
the spectator i asked him the same
question and he thinks
kind of the same outcome as you but in a
totally different way thinks it's going
to be so contested
because of accusations of mailing fraud
and if the dems win no one's going to
win by a landslide i think i think it's
going to be tight
and if the republicans win it will be
accusations of
trump's manipulated the postal thing and
do this yes and it's the same in reverse
right so
that that is a and i only learned this
on a on a podcast and i've had like a
i'm so glad that i have no uh
sort of horse in this race because
that's a real existential threat man
like you know given
how inflammatory everything is in the
states at the moment
and then add on top the fact that no one
really trusts anyone especially party to
party
and everything's been primed for
november it would almost be best if it
was a landslide
if it's a if it's a 55 45 a 60 40
great if it's a 50.49 point
yes holy [ __ ] no you're right i think
the odds that
look in the scenario that biden wins the
odds that donald trump says hey
we tried our hardest but congratulations
to president biden i'm going to see
myself out now
the odds of that occurs are zero point
zero percent
not zero point one zero point zero zero
zero percent no chance that
that that occurs and in any scenario
which bind wins i think you're right
the odds that it's gonna be dragged out
in the courts as it was with uh george
bush and al gore
20 years ago are extremely high i don't
think anyone expects to wake up the day
after the election and know
with certainty all around who the
president is but that is a very
important
part of our democratic system in 2016
from what i understand barack obama
called hillary clinton the night of the
election and said
you need to concede i know this is not
the outcome that any one of us wanted
but is integral to the democracy of the
united states that the loser concedes
and hillary clinton did at the start of
her press conference the next morning
the day after the election
she stood in front of the microphone and
said donald trump will be our next
president
you know how much that had to rip her to
shreds inside but she said it because it
is so
important and what's what's crazy that
you
that you reference here and i think it's
totally right is the odds that that
occurs this year
virtually zero virtually zero so you
take something that has been so
important to our democracy
and you think well there's no way it's
going to happen and it's a big threat
big threat
[Laughter]
if you know what it is like 2020 is some
history for you
if nothing else we were we were kind of
missing a bit of history
2010 to 2019 we just had social media
and like tick tocks
there's no history and then this we just
had latent
latent history all caught up to us and
gave us
[ __ ] whiplash at the game charging
there's this great quote from
nassim taleb who says history does not
crawl it leaps
that was that's what it is history is
not something that moves slowly over
time history is something that flatlines
and then
boom comes out of you from the middle of
nowhere
and you're right that's what 2020 is
some history for you look morgan
man psychology money will be linked in
the show notes below
i implore you to go and check it out if
ever there was a year where you need
some financial advice
it would be this one and i you know it's
everything that we've been through today
plus more james clear
daniel pink annie duke who is coming on
this show next week
for her new book uh and howard marks
like you've just got the biggest
the biggest swinging dicks of uh of risk
and
of uh psychology just on your butt so
why not why not do it um
morgan housel at morgan housel on
twitter that's where you live
anything else that people should oh
collaborative fund clever fun blog
that's where he has the book you got the
twitter you got the blog
that's it well that's the thing after
three episodes man i can just do
if you need me to drive the kids to
school or any other things
like you know i just know what i'm doing
so man it is you're
you're part of the family now i
appreciate it that's the way it works
and we've got a little visitor just
behind you have a look
is she is she here that's part of the
family you're gonna be driving her to
school soon that's the plan
um man it is always such a pleasure to
speak to you i'm looking forward to the
next one already thank you so much
thanks again chris this has been fun as
always
[Music]